دي خطوه ارادت معها وزاره العدل ان تاخذ
موقفا محيدا من قضيه اكتشاف وثائق لدى
رؤساء امريكيين عين المدعي العام
مستشارا خاصا لتوليد تحقيق في المستندات
السريه التي تم العثور عليها في منزل
الرئيس جو بايدن و مكتبه
الخاصا وفقا للوائح وزاره العدل التي تحكم
في مثل هذه الظروف
اوليه قام بها المدعي الامريكي في شيكاغو
كما يؤدي الى زياده الانكشاف القانوني
ومحاميه الذين تعاملوا مع مواد حكوميه
حساسه حين كان نائبا للرئيس
وبتعيمه مستشاره خاصه يعطل المدعي العام
جارل نفسه عن هذه القضيه الحساسه السياسيه
على الرغم من انه سيظل له الكلمه الاخيره
بشان ما اذا كان سيواجه ايتها ماتا عندما
ينتهي التحقيق
تماما عندما وجد هذه الوثائق وعلى الفور
تم التواصل مع الارشيف الوطني وتم الاتصال
بوزاره العدل تصريحات البيت الابيض قد
تكون شراء الوقت ولكن بغض النظر عن
النتيجه النهائيه موضوع الوثائق سيكون
نقطه ساخنه في سباق الرئاسي لعام 2014
التي قد تصل الى حد العسل
يمثل التعيين لحظه مهمه لبعيد ويمثل لحظه
فريده في التاريخ الامريكي مع مستشارين
خاصين يحققان مع الرئيس الحالي وسلفه
المباشر في النفس الوقت تحقيق المستشار
الخاص يعني الى جانب مجلس النواب العدواني
الجديد بقياده الجمهوريين ان بعيدا قد
يكون في موقف دفاعي خلال العامين المقبلين
ريتا سليمان العربيه واشنطن